welcome to this video playing your feet
from Germany that's not nice why not
call yourself your friend isn't a small
nice no name right no there's a very new
account has only played down a couple of
games and only five minute games let's
see yeah we have though the only Bishop
before check which is normally Carter
carers defense and that's a really one
of the better sight lines it's um very
comparable to the bogo of course but
delaying Knight f6 is often an
interesting point he now has played
Knight f6 rather quickly so we have
transposed into a normal Bongo Indian
now hmm yeah I can go III g3 knocked
okay let's let's get the bishops okay
yes a phone now maybe I should have
prevented dead but if he goes a 4 I can
play a form and then he has a hard time
to prevent you 45 okay and that's so not
so easy anyway at the moment you 45 sir
some accomplishment for white black
really would like to yes yeah this is
this as possible and in fact
let me I have analyzed this in my book
believe it or not we have transposed to
them we have transposed to the to the
Zurich variation of the news oh and this
is the line that I have analyzed it's
not enough compensation for black but I
have forgotten the details ok and now I
think I can take and that probably
should take a forest think not good if i
remember correctly Queen takes song
it should be 3r I cannot really remember
I cannot remember how exactly it is
played Queen g6 castles bishop age three
days f3 yeah here must castle
okay I really don't know this is not
really a great position for them for the
bishop I go here yeah maybe quindi for
Queen F to the other bishan is just the
bishop is just biting dreddit that is
the default poem here Wow and this I
thought would be really helpful for me I
mean the Queen trade is basically like
giving up on this game so you must
retreat okay maybe yeah still still it
should be okay
check so if i take this only the c-4
pawn on the light square I wonder about
the bishop c2 though this might be a
very direct way to to continue he has F
form maybe but then g3 I immediately get
this pawn roller now insert be very good
takes Bishop takes a text be 77 yeah now
i get this mentioned on roller ah ok ah
i get this too quickly i played this too
quickly
I might manage to get the only way to e5
a disposal this was really bad technical
plane
check okay if he goes King 'if i have
king g5
ah ah that's really how I love this this
end game what the heck did i do there g3
Bishop website and then I'd why I just
wanted to take f4 and he just it's just
over and instead I'm playing this
automatic move it completely completely
idiotic really idiotic okay let's let's
see maybe I can still try something but
it's just just idiotic a ho jati flame
ok I think I can I can still try to win
here because the King invades its
protected person counts for something
but still it was terrible play really
terrible yeah but i think i'm cooking
black resins and maybe maybe it was
still a win but really really crazy play
here and after this I just need to take
I need to take on f4 and it's over now I
just have this pawn pawn mass in the
center I can i can easily advance it
it's not like he can block it I can play
a 5 f-5 and get the King involved and
this is just very easy and after that
it's not it's not clear if I can win
this because I'm located on the light
squares I just played this like
automatically and it's just stupid just
stupid I must take here it's the only
way to justify also this this play with
them with with Bishop c2 I mean the
simple approach is just to take and win
this end game I only have this pawn
misplaced on a light square but other
than that is just the extra porn on the
King side which should win and I only
thought that this is easier because this
is so simple and I underestimated I
didn't really think about this move I
thought you must take and then it's also
easy the after Bishop by 7i just played
this kind of reflects move Bishop d3
yeah I really made it to make life art
for myself the question is still ok mean
he had the chance to play you five maybe
this is better it's probably for sure
that I'm
okay but I had this idea which I tried
in the game too yeah the question is
maybe he can just stay put here yeah of
course he does not need to play King e5
not that this is necessarily bad but
yeah if he just he just stays doing
nothing basically and I try to try to
invade him the computer is giving it as
dead equal but I don't understand the ad
why am I not invading him cannot see now
it is entering I it's entering to go to
e3 ah of course PIAA this can can easily
backfire let's just just just follow a
possible line or maybe black should move
it ma'am let's bounce the bishop
yeah that's the wrong that's a drone so
it was still a draw yeah it may mean
must be I played it so I played it so
badly it's really deserved of course
what I really should do is after he I
should play five instead of the keenest
this is still securing some some
advantage I guess not sure if i can win
but it's it's it's something of course
as i showed it before I mean it was much
easier with with other other approaches
okay thanks for watching